the true epidemic is depression and
people from all over the world now more
than ever are suffering from it and in
this video i'm going to share four
things in fact maybe five
that worked for me so quickly to cure my
depression after years of suffering from
it and i am convinced that if it worked
for me it will work for you or others
and if you haven't experienced
depression yourself it is a guarantee
that you know someone in your life
probably multiple people friends or
family or whoever that have suffered
from it as well now let me just say real
quick i'm going to speak off the cuff i
have a couple notes in front of me
but this is not going to be my typical
video where i script it out so if i
ramble on a bit bear with me but i it is
worth it and this if it doesn't apply to
you
this video will be something that can
help somebody else i truly believe that
and i told myself years ago because my
goal was to create a youtube channel and
discuss topics that i love and bring
light and information to others and i
told myself once i got big enough
i would share things that would truly
help humanity and this video was long
overdue so let me just dive into it
i was depressed for a few years and i
believe that it was induced by a knee
surgery that i had that caused me to be
essentially couch ridden for almost five
months and i believe that that lack of
exercise sunlight and everything else
is just
it changed something in my brain
and
i hate to admit it but i did try
antidepressants uh it was encouraged by
other people i knew that had tried it
and i did the base entry level
it was zoloft 50 milligram which is
considered like the minimum but i don't
recommend it i did it for four months
did not help me
and although i know other people that it
did help and they say it changed their
lives forever
um
to me for most people it's like putting
a band-aid on a broken bone so i am not
about to recommend pharmaceuticals to
you
so let me tell you what i am
recommending and let me start off with
the thing that made the most
unbelievable difference within days i
couldn't even believe it
so
a dry sauna
that is something i first tried on
january 1st 2020
and
the
after that first day i felt amazing but
by the second day and especially the
third is when i realized it was like the
depression was cured now if you haven't
experienced depression it's almost
unexplainable in that it's not sadness
it's not feeling down in the dumps it's
quite literally
uh something in your brain that causes
you to not be able to focus you lose
drive to be able to do things in your
life um for me i pulled back from
friends and family
because that's the thing you need to
understand is that there's so many
people suffering from depression but a
lot of them are going to hide it like i
did i didn't want people to know that
there was something off of you know
going on in my head where i felt like
you know
unmotivated to do things
um and it's heartbreaking to share that
with other people and a lot of people
keep things pent up so
long story short i started using a dry
sauna because i had heard profound
effects uh
including longevity like people that use
sauna from around the world the studies
are all over the place that shows that
if you use a sauna three days a week for
15 minutes you will live longer it's
significant reduction in
heart disease cancer
um uh alzheimer's and dementia and
that's a big deal
but long story short i started using a
sauna at my gym um because i couldn't
afford one and i hope to buy one myself
so if you can't afford asana either
because they're thousands of dollars get
a damn gym membership and start doing
this immediately go at least three four
days a week no less than 15 minutes at
least 175 degrees
i have never tried these infrared ones
these are
those wavelength things look
maybe they work maybe they don't i don't
know all i know is that natural heat has
got to be the way to go because i am
convinced that it like cooked something
out of my brain
and it worked within days guys you have
to try this i've recommended this to
other people in my life that suffer from
depression and they still haven't tried
the sauna you know why because they
don't feel like going to the gym getting
changed in the locker room and just
being out of their comfort zone
and to be honest with you i had
prolonged
my first time going to the to the sauna
for months i got the gm i had a gym
membership they didn't have a sauna so i
got a second membership at a place that
did and then it was like three four
months before i finally went and was on
january 1st 2020. so by sitting in there
i'm convinced it cooks something out of
you you have to try it it will make you
feel good it burns the toxins out of
your body and if there was one thing and
one thing only that had the most
profound effect on me it was that try it
secondly
now this is going to apply more to men
but it involves testosterone
we have reduced testosterone in this
modern age because we are not doing
things like we used to the the things
that mankind was meant to do like be
outside more and getting vitamin d using
our legs like whether it's bending down
and freaking harvesting crops or hunting
it is proven that testosterone higher
testosterone alleviates depression and
it is also proven that we have lower
testosterone now because we are sitting
around all day in cubicles and on the
couch and we're not living the lifestyle
that humans were meant to live
long story short
there are studies that prove that people
who do leg exercises leg press squats
it boosts your testosterone
and when i started doing leg exercises
that had a profound effect on me as well
a lot of people go to the gym
and they're like you know how guys are
they'll do their upper body and no lower
body they skip the leg day right guys
try this if you don't want to go to the
gym do some lunges in your house down
the hallway do some like squats lean
against the freaking wall whatever you
got to do it will help
another little thing you can do and this
is this is getting personal and this
will be a video for itself
but for you men to boost your
testosterone you need to stop
masturbating so often
a by prolonging studies show that by day
seven of you not ejaculating your
testosterone is up one hundred and fifty
percent one five zero
that in itself guys guys you're addicted
to porn you're addicted to the dopamine
rush when you jerk off
and
same thing for sex addicts too probably
you shouldn't be getting off quite as
often as you are now i will make a video
on what's called semen retention this is
getting a little bit personal and it's
not what this video is about and if
women are listening like well how does
this help me well it might help a guy
you know that's depressed right so keep
that in mind there are things you can do
to elevate your testosterone leg
exercises
not freaking ejaculating so often
sunlight and other things google it how
to naturally increase your testosterone
do that that is one of the primary
reasons for depression um
but here's something else and this is
just as profound as everything else that
i just mentioned between the sauna and
the in the testosterone which is
purpose and goals
purpose fixes everything in creating
goals even small it could be for example
oh okay i'm going to go to the gym four
days this week for no less than a half
hour each day that is a goal and you're
going to write it down on a piece of
paper and you scratch it off and it's
going to feel real good when you
complete it
goals could be
it could be something work related it
could be something with friends and
family it could be volunteering it could
be a million different things
but goals and purpose is
guys this is one of the hugest things
too i don't know what's causing
depression more than anything it could
be one more than the other it could be
different people effects differently or
it could be all the above but i can tell
you right now that there's nothing more
satisfying than have a life purpose and
let me give you a short story because
this is really interesting so i'm an
iraq war veteran i had volunteered i was
inspired by 9 11. i now my views have
changed traumatically i believe it was a
massive crime against humanity and
everything else but what i can tell you
is that when i was doing missions in
iraq
i
have never felt better in my life now i
didn't shoot anybody that's not what i'm
saying here but i believed at the time
that i was liberating the iraqi people
and i was putting myself in danger there
was this excitement of going outside the
wire with a freaking machine gun and not
knowing if you're going to get blown up
that day
and and having that that that
feeling of that i was protecting
somebody because back in the day like
when we were more tribal you know there
was that feeling where you couldn't just
like sit around lounging around you know
without protecting your tribe so to
speak there was that feeling if you
could get invaded by marauders or
another tribe or whoever it may have
been another empire
and
and
so having that sense of like you know
the unknown in danger and that we're not
living such a cushy comfortable life
that is something that's played a part
in it as well
um i can tell you i have taken great
inspiration from different people
athletes whoever i mean i might just be
some youtube nerd but there's someone i
love who's tyson fury he's a heavyweight
boxing champion of the world lineal
champion i love the guy and he's been
very outspoken about his own
mental health issues and depression and
one of the things he had mentioned was
that creating goals even small ones he's
like i'm gonna i'm gonna run a mile
today and start with that that's a goal
it doesn't have to be exercising i
mentioned going to the gym earlier
get creative but you need to find your
purpose purpose fixes everything mental
health your relationships with friends
and family your work if you have a
guy's purpose could be a million
different things
you know i'm still looking for my
purpose like some people think oh it's
you know talking the ancients and
sharing things on youtube but part of me
is like man i want to help humanity and
leave this place better it was than
before i got here so i'm letting that
feel me as well and and even this video
knowing that i have the following that i
do that by sharing this video if it
could help just one person it would be
worth it that's part of a purpose but
purpose doesn't have to be fixing
anything or helping anyone on some grand
scale purpose could be just being good
to your kids or rate helping your nieces
and nephews have a good upbringing or
volunteering for something you know
it could be
ah you know
it could be one million different things
and if you could think of something on
how people could find their purpose
leave a comment down below but this ties
into my next point which is that
you have to be around people you have to
be around friends and family when i was
depressed i pulled back from everyone
and i just want to stay home all the
time
and it felt impossible to go out now i
understand that when you're depressed
you're not going to feel like going to
the gym you're not going to feel like
going out with friends you're not going
to feel like there's any drive or
purpose in your life at all and this is
where this little part comes in which is
that
this is a war against yourself
the war on drugs the war on terror the
war on anything does not work it is
counterproductive
but i'm telling you right now
this is a battle against yourself you
have to get your butt off that damn
couch and you're going to go to the gym
and you're going to work out and you're
going to try you're going to go outside
and get some fresh air and breathe in
you know get the sunlight
you have got to fight your way out of
this
that is what got me like
it took january 1st for me to finally go
to the damn sauna for the first time and
i didn't feel like going but i finally
just said [ __ ] it go like i was
that feeling of despair was just
i had hit my breaking point i'm like
it's time to get busy living or get busy
dying and i'm telling you right now the
sooner you make changes in your life
because you always have a choice you do
have free will and those who tell you
that you don't are massively misinformed
the only way you don't have free will
is if you lack the awareness of what
that you do that you can make choices
choices and decisions in your life that
can change your life forever
you can do this
now
that being said um there are a number of
other things too smaller things
um in no particular order like i already
said vitamin d get outside eat fruits
and vegetables if you don't like fruits
and vegetables it's because you're
addicted to crap food and you need to
change that crap up you need to be
eating garlic and everything else
there's so many different types of food
that will boost your immune system and
i'm convinced that by having a higher
immune system your brain will function
better as well
um
a couple other things now this is where
it gets touchy
so
some people
let me just say i was using cannabis
marijuana for depression
and it helped greatly
however
if you're going to go down that path you
need to understand that it will keep you
depressed
alcohol cannabis those things in in the
moment like while you're having this up
feeling
it's like the depression goes away
that's why people do drugs to feel good
it's not because there's some piece of
[ __ ] it's because they're trying to feel
good in life
but i'm telling you right now like the
weed thing i used to be a complete
advocate for it well i still am but i'm
telling you that if you suffer from
depression
it might if you haven't tried weed
before there are certain strains that
are known to alleviate depression and i
would encourage you to try it but you
have to go into it with a game plan
knowing that it's temporary
do it for a number of months if you need
to to try to like get yourself out of
the day-to-day of like complete
suffering
but
i'm telling you right now
you're gonna have to kick it you're
gonna have to get rid of it at some
point to truly escape the depression
it's true took a long time for me to
finally admit that
um
other things sleep routine get good
sleep that matters um
but the power of belief
is everything
believing that you can be happy because
you had been happy before you there was
one point in your life that you weren't
depressed at least i hope some people
suffered it from day one as children and
still do today but now is the time for
you to try the things i just told you
but the belief that you can
leave be alleviated of your suffering
is
it cannot be overstated on how powerful
that is
try it
so where was i what else
guys that's it
use the sauna
it worked it worked for me day one but i
realized that it was like a cure by day
two and three i was like am i just
feeling good today because it was like
is it placebo like i think let me just
say i didn't go into it no one was gonna
cure me of depression but after the
first day i'm like why i feel so good
today for the rest of day i felt awesome
so i'm like you know
was that me thinking in my head that it
had made some difference but it wasn't
until a few days in that i was like oh
my god this is like it's like it didn't
even happen
the depression
so there's that
leg exercise this applies to women as
well um but you need to do things to
increase your testosterone for men
particularly um and purpose and goals
again purpose fixes everything
again also war against yourself
that is the real thing here we're
against anything else don't work but
this you're gonna have to fight your way
out of this and you can and you will if
i did it you can do it because at one
point
at many points i felt like
it felt impossible but i also still
believe that one day i would feel better
so you need to believe it too
anyways i'm going to close this up
because
yeah i'm already rambling i already said
the same thing's over i want to keep
this short and sweet i don't want to
make the video too long
but try these things out if it worked
for me it can work for you
share this with other people i guarantee
there's people in your life that need it
and leave a comment down below to say
and share what's worked for you but try
it what have you got to lose get busy
living or get busy dying you owe it to
yourself you owe it to everything
to to get out of this mess because
if you check out and go down that
suicide path like some people do you're
going to cause a lot of suffering to
others
don't be a selfish person because that's
what that is and i say with love and
respect because i know people have taken
their lives since the most heartbreaking
thing ever
so
anyways my name is jimmy corsetti my
channel is called bright insight
i have many videos on lots of different
topics and like i said when i made this
channel i was making videos on all kinds
of different topics when i first started
this and now i'm getting back to my
roots i have other videos and agents
coming but i have other videos on other
amazing topics coming as well so all
that said i'll close it up here
take care everybody